San Francisco is known for coffee right
right specifically like niche coffee
which is probably like an expresso bar
so just think expresso there's no K in
it
it's just espresso what there's coffee
in it oh go go differences go go to KBT
that expresses the espresso agogo in San
Francisco Co 2k15 before we go off
tasting in San Francisco we decided we
need to figure out what makes coffee
good cuz we don't know what makes coffee
good cuz we're a nyet we don't know much
about expresso espresso is a I ask you
questions about espresso so what what
should we be looking for
a lot of body to it right that wow
factor every adventure is there ever
like a sex appeal to an expresso shot oh
yeah cool cool I think we was great
can't stop having fun are we really
gonna just walk around San Francisco all
day
yeah we're used to Los Angeles where we
just get to drive around so maybe we can
figure out an alternative like a fun
alternative like a fun little yellow
alternative I've been rather dry so the
first place up so the first place we're
headed to is Starbuck goddammit Brent's
calling me
hello we're going to Starbucks
we can park it like a car you know it's
aren't even allowed in here oh thanks
anyway it's we're definitely not
supposed to be allowed to come to this
Starbucks whatever I got a water and two
specials to go go this is what it looks
like inside of the cup ready got its
aroma chocolatey burn a little bit of
coffee three notes okay Cheers
oh it's awful this was a person it would
be a very out of shape angry person
it kind of tastes like acid every sip is
worse if this is my sense of adventure
this is going to be a bad trip well this
is my first expresso ever so espresso
yeah let's hope for better on the
espresso agogo in San Francisco Co 2k15
I put time to beans and them down and um
a button into a cup and a bit a little
bit
Tabata render filter it rips and
trumpety trypsin I take the SIP bin
again it I'll buy any espresso no matter
the cost I'm looking down on my phone
cuz we straight-up lost
well not that lost we're just hitting in
a park but together we'll make a bunch
of sparks lunch a fire
fire tell you that you should desire
hole around over right from Grant Achatz
yeah pour in the copy right into a cup I
just can't believe this is a thing they
let tourists just drive around
seems like a hazard nice we're at Pete's
coffee it's a grocery store but I think
there's a peace sign hey could I get two
espressos two googa smell I'm really
only getting chocolate and coffee
there's something like kind of muddy
about it maybe we'll mint for hands what
about the impact it was like a crescendo
not okay this is a nice thick body woman
not basic at all there's not a lot of
bass to it I wish we had a litmus paper
the sense of adventure this is a boat
tour yeah it says having a fun time with
your mom does it get a sexy not know is
it attractive yeah like a mother is over
all we'd say Pete's coffee is the mother
to this expresso agogo in San Francisco
Co 2k15 thanks mom
it's espresso espresso agogo in San
Francisco Co espresso agogo in San
Francisco Co we cruise around in a tiny
little car having minikin sacani am i
doing it [ __ ]
this is our first drinking taste buds we
get two shots of espresso to go go yeah
oh yeah
violet Coffee Co man it's a code 7 Cisco
Co San Francisco Co it smells like
chocolate chip ice creams and it smells
like nature a little bit too marshmallow
say at least five minutes ooh M hack I
went through three tastes in that first
set it's got a light body to it in but
like that light body is bangin well this
is so sick this is like drinking a sour
juice I feel like I just got great yeah
sometimes you just the first step and
you're like whoa I'm there and I'm like
what are you talking about and then this
I'm there it's all over your mouth
it's a totally different experience
tasting something like that it's a sense
of adventure I feel like I just left on
a voyage my mouth is now spaced wow
factor and so out of this world Wow
this almost makes me aroused I'm happy
to give this my sexy nod cuz I'm blown
away by more fun than sex I feel like
this is erotic espresso agogo in San
Francisco Co you get your feet I'm
having a blast yo I'm in like Castro
low your hands away you ask though you
asked for it I gave it to you you got a
question I got that frankly on the west
coast where the [ __ ] at can we look
around caller where's I be cheated and
what's happened so much fun we don't
serve for nothing we just drive around
the cars and have fun for fun and we
doing and we're doing it we're doing it
all day and we're having fun and we're
totally friends and what happened it
yeah yeah I'm all do if you go back to
the police every like a little buddy to
go pump thanks Sam hey I don't know the
spoon is for four barrel smells really
good
yeah live on your nose would candy or
something like a corn sweetness like a
sour patch like Nilla wafers yeah Cheers
is it weird that my first inclination is
a color Oh yellow I would say like
yellow green body I'm looking it looks
like a like a map I feel like it's the
most acidic so far but it's almost like
there should be a different word for
this taste yeah now we don't know a dark
sour it's like a riddle of an adventure
cuz you're like trying to figure it out
it's like down a rabbit hole I give this
the wow factor cuz I'm boggle it's like
the new Kendrick Lamar album you gotta
listen to it over and over again to
really get it
this is dog do you back you know the
more and more I drink I realize how
shitty the Starbucks one was know what I
want to do though we went in Blue Bottle
we met Brin Brin taught us about coffee
he showed us their coffee we went around
the city but we never tried bluebottles
espresso right I feel like we should go
back and give that a try everywhere
- everywhere you look
this sounds like this car is working
really hard no
the throttle right now
Oh No here wait wait you're gonna pull
over over there ready
all right no problem everything's good
cars dyin call Brent hey we just broke
down no we're just gonna go return it
because we're worried can you hear me
hello to try again
what could possibly go wrong ready yeah
now see if it moves
we're good
we're back going at the Estrella he'll
go in San Francisco go we're back baby
don't run over there come on over write
that oh let's go go go in San Francisco
Co 2k15
this is where I said to drop it off it
all comes full circle it's where we
began it's where we're gonna end
Abdi Dez my bow goes to it again to the
camp espresso agogo in San Francisco Co
2k15 so we're back at Blue Bottle we did
it a bunch of wonderful people met up
with us from Twitter Twitter oh wow oh
it's okay it's just Marilyn Monroe II
know let's take a sniff yeah yeah we're
trying a heli nose yeah join a chocolaty
kind of nutty and the other note lighter
you really got it yeah impact design X
10mm that's when you're on a roller
coaster and it does the you sort of fall
but oh you didn't then you fall yeah
yeah what about the body it's like soft
soap in yeah I think the girl from lay
your body is a wonderland video the
acidity is like it's there right yeah
it's not like flying flying hard it's
like one of those love boat rides yeah I
was where he's driving it's like kind of
dark and you're like I don't know about
this and then all these things start
scaring you and like what scares you
want a love boat ride I don't know that
commitment mate yeah overall Blue Bottle
gets a while fat yeah and bring gets a
wow factor as a sensei espresso sense
okay you feel free to walk through this
is just a street this is just a street
are you giving this your sexy nod or are
we just gonna give it to Bryn I think
I'm gonna give Bryn my sexy my friend
gets an intellectual sexy knife oh my I
am NOT physical I'll give it to it okay
it's been a good day a little passion
and you know not only did we sense
adventure we had an adventure on the go
going damages go go you gave a teen this
pressed oh yeah Express espresso I
thought it was supposed to be expressive
hey Chris how do you feel at the end of
the night of the day that we did the
coffee video I feel I feel terrible